meantime Jojo Genoveva has been around
these issues for a long time as a former
US Attorney for the District of Columbia
and he joins us in the studio tonight
jokes are coming on my pleasure so the
first question is is a topical one there
been news reports all day that the FBI
director I know if these are true or not
but it's threatening to resign and I
hope he does so what is that about
what's where these stories coming from
are they true Chris Rea planted these
stories himself but who's trying to show
the employees of the FBI and the former
agents that he's brave he's stalwart
he's standing up for them this is
nonsensical if he offers to resign the
president should accept his resignation
this type of behavior by an FBI director
is childish it's immature and let me say
that after since August the Congress has
been seeking the documents which are
going to be revealed somewhat in the
four-page memorandum which demonstrates
the corruption on the seventh floor the
FBI and at the Department of Justice
under Comey and and others it is it is
inconceivable to me that Ray has to turn
to a threat of resignation to make
himself look good it displays a lack of
leadership lack of competence and an
inability to understand the times in
which you function as a major leader a
leader of an American institution in
addition it shows an arrogance toward
congressional oversight the the notion
of going to the Speaker of the House and
saying Mr Speaker we really don't want
you to publish this memo what in the
name of god is wrong at the top of the
FBI but on what Gragas well I'm confused
by like most Americans I'm always
willing to give the benefit of the doubt
to the FBI too lon yes to Intel agencies
it's it's my government yes I don't
understand the rationale and what makes
me nervous what makes me think it might
just be but covering is they never
explain why the country would be
imperiled by the release of the
information one of the things that's
terrible about this is this both Chris
Rhea and rod Rosenstein the Deputy
Attorney General have done a miserable
job as leaders in explaining why they're
doing what they're doing why they can't
do what people want them to do you know
what Chris Rea was arguing for yesterday
and today to remove the names of all the
the FBI agents and the DOJ people who
in the law and are going to be revealed
in the memorandum but on what grounds I
mean how would the public benefit being
the redaction of those they wouldn't and
it's not about the public this is the
arrogance of Ray and Rosenstein they
want to protect the bureaucracy they
want to protect the bureaucracy because
they think the institutions are more
important than you or I knowing anything
and they think the country cannot
survive with Adam this is this phoney
notion that DOJ and the FBI are
independent of the executive branch and
the President of the United States it is
an insidious concept they work for the
president he can fire them he can tell
them what to do that doesn't mean he's
going to interfere in an investigation
but the arrogance of Ray and Rosenstein
to think that they can defy
congressional oversight and ask the
speaker to take out the names of people
that have broken the law how outrageous
so what do you make of the argument from
the left I'm speaking now of the Jolla
every red-faced talk show host and phony
pundit on cable news yapping away that
to ask questions like the ones you're
asking demonstrates a lack of respect
for law enforcement you don't appreciate
the work they do the risks they take
you're basically unpatriotic for wanting
to what your government is do yet well
let me just say this I've been a federal
prosecutor and an investigator for more
than 30 years I've had my family
threatened by drug dealers and
terrorists this is nonsensical
we all respect the street agents we
respect the prosecutors at the career
level of the Justice Department what we
are talking about here is criticism of
political appointees at the FBI and
political appointees at the Department
of Justice this has nothing to do with
the street agents the arguments of the
left are phony arguments designed to
make it look like people like me who are
critical of the FBI in the situation are
critical of everyone that's nonsense
so when Joan Walsh on CNN suggests they
are unpatriotic for asking questions
about what your government is doing you
don't feel on patriotic switch no
actually it's not a question of
patriotism as an old US Attorney I don't
like dirty cops and the seventh floor
the FBI is full of them and the upper
echelon of the DOJ under Obama was full
of dirty cops and look what they did
they threw a case against Hillary
Clinton like a bunch of lousy 19
thirty's prizefighters for 500 bucks and
they tried to frame Donald Trump with a
created crime seems like our patriotic
duty would be to to untangle the mess
find out what happened let's find out
let's find out what happened let's
unseal the memo amen
so thank you for that you're welcome